donald trump contra las cuerdas la
arenga a sus simpatizantes que desembocó
en el asalto al capitolio dejo al
presidente saliente aislado y ante la
amenaza de una posible destitución para
ellos se manejan varias opciones aunque
difíciles de resolver entre los
demócratas la consigna es clara debe
haber consecuencias
al pedir este acto sedicioso el
presidente ha cometido un asalto
indescriptible contra nuestra nación y
nuestro pueblo
se hará justicia a los que llevaron a
cabo estos actos que fueron actos de
sedición y cobardía
como primera alternativa a los líderes
demócratas en el congreso pidieron
invocar la enmienda 25 que permite la
sustitución de un presidente considerado
incapaz para ejercer el cargo esa
compleja medida necesita el apoyo del
vicepresidente y una mayoría del
gabinete una opción que mike pence no
estaría dispuesto a llevar adelante en
este escenario se fortalece la idea de
iniciar un proceso de impeachment
express mientras los demócratas de la
cámara se preparan para presentar una
acusación contra trompo por insurrección
el juicio político debería llevarse a
cabo en el senado que está en receso
hasta después de la toma de posesión de
joe biden no obstante el proceso podría
continuar incluso cuando trump dejara el
cargo y potencialmente podría impedirle
ser candidato en 2024 como ha sugerido y
ocupar cargos públicos
la descalificación para ocupar más
cargos federales cuando hay acciones
como las que hemos visto el presidente
trump esta semana es totalmente
apropiada
cualquiera de los escenarios es de
difícil resolución y pondría al
presidente electo joe biden en una
posición incómoda de cara al inicio de
su gobierno el mandatario entrante
consideró que trompo no está apto para
ejercer el cargo pero evitó referirse a
un potencial juicio político alegando
que esa es competencia del congreso